schulden durch an ein shopping dass es
keine seltenheit stimmen bei öffentlich
zu sprechen schon seit neuestem gibt es
aber einen tick tock trend unter dem
hashtag planer schulden posten junge
menschen über ihre online shopping
schulden beim circus kleiner schulen
wünsche zu weihnachten geld und was
machst du denn nicht kleiner schulden
begleichen mehr die private insolvenz
wohl zu viele klar schulden auch mit
sie hat mir ihre geschichte erzählt also
ich hab immer sachen bestellt und immer
auf ich teile auch später gemacht und
dann bin ich in diesen großen tiefen
schwarzen loch gefallen bin sehr viele
offene beträge und sehr hohen zahl auch
tatsächlich an einen shopping
verschönert disco war komplett
ausgeschöpft die bank hat mit keinen
kein aufruf mehr gewährt wenn man ist
nicht mehr erhöht und ich habe dann
recht realisiert okay wenn ich jetzt
nicht ich kann meine somit nicht mehr
zahlen ich kann man nicht mehr 20
termine zu essen kaufen dass man
trotzdem weiter shoppen kann und wo man
vielleicht gerade gar kein geld dafür
hat das machen nur unternehmen die
planer paypal unmöglich jetzt einkaufen
und später bezahlen so das versprechen
beim pay later nennt man diese
bezahlmethode doch welche gefahren
stecken hinter diese bezahlmethode und
wie leicht ist es in eine schuldenfalle
abzurutschen darum geht's in diesem
video und wenn ihr vielleicht schulden
habt und ein paar tipps wie er da wieder
rauskommt bleibt bis zum ende dran da
haben wir ein paar infos für euch
[Musik]
ich selbst habe auch schon mit der
bezahlmethode beinahe pay later auf
rechnung bestellt einfach weil ich mir
meine hose nicht sicher aber welche die
richtige größe für mich ist der slogan
zahl doch ein paar später was du
wirklich behältst hat mich dann
irgendwie schnell überzeugt ich musste
nur mein geburtsdatum angeben und meine
e-mail-adresse und schon weil der kauf
abgeschlossen einfach und simpel so wie
versprochen einfach war es für tom am
anfang auch er 27 jahre alt und arbeitet
als fotograf bei no pay later hat er
lange zeit intensiv genutzt dass er ein
werk verschollen hatte gerade ende des
monats ist geld ist eh nicht so viel da
nicht so 18 nicht schlimm in zwei wochen
kommt der gehalt und dann bezahle ist
eben mit und dann kommen die forderung
und die ganzen anderen
lebenshaltungskosten und habe ich dann
doch schnell gott mein geld ist weg
man hat sie aber doch noch andere sachen
bestellt man doch gerne haben wollte
also hat kann seine rechnungen immer
wieder aufgeschoben doch irgendwann gab
es die erste mahnung
schaut man sich das halt schön geredet
man wollte es nicht einsehen dass man
doch irgendwie scheiße gebaut hat
und damit war ein sony enge getrieben
dass ich mich folgenden familie öffnen
musste auch meter lange zeit sehr viel
geschockt dass sie mit 20 vor drei
jahren keinen überblick mehr über ihre
rechnungen hatte zwar ein scheiß gefühl
weil da waren auch sagen dabei die ich
gar nicht benötigt habe ich hatte genug
klamotten so sehr aber man wollte ja
auch immer
auf den neusten stand sein sag ich jetzt
mal so gesagt jeder holztage ist na ja
es kommen neue sachen braucht man möchte
sofort holen am liebsten heartmate mit
dem zahlungsdienstleister clara bestellt
deswegen schauen wir uns jetzt die seite
mal ein bisschen genauer an der seite
sind echt total ansprechend aus alles
was hier so in pastelltönen und die
slogans sind total einprägsam wie jetzt
bezahle später erlebe news shopping
mein kind jetzt seine farbe - müsste das
geld und finanzen geht bin ich eher
denken dass ich auch eine seite für
einen online-shop unterwegs bin das
bestätigt auch für vorwerk von der
verbraucherzentrale nrw
präsentiert sich lifestyle ich aber wer
das dann mehrfach in anspruch nimmt wird
feststellen so einfach ist das shoppen
nicht das shoppen selber schon aber die
bezahlung ich wollte es ist ja nicht
mehr geld auf dem konto diese
schmerzhafte erfahrung musste auch
mitmachen irgendwann hatte sie mehr als
1000 euro schulden monatlich würden die
rechnungen halt da war ich gebe
abbezahlt habe dass ich hatte einfach
für das monatlich zwei übrig hatte da
habe ich gemerkt ich muss jetzt mal
langsam die not present notbremse sind
sie weil ich jetzt nicht so lang so
leben möchte über schulen spricht man
ich gerne und natürlich möchte man nicht
schnell wieder loswerden manche schaffen
dass er dann nur mit einer
schuldnerberatung auffällig ist dass 25
bis 44 jährige besonders oft zur
schuldnerberatung gegen sie machen es da
nur 30,2 prozent der gesamtbevölkerung
aus aber trotzdem sind sie die
altersgruppe die am häufigsten zur
beratungsstelle geht ein möglicher grund
das bezahlmodell bei no pay later
jetzt steht weihnachten vor der tür und
das ein oder andere geschenk wird
bestimmt wieder online geshoppt zu
solchen anlässen gibt eine pay later
porsche das bezahlmodell funktioniert so
wenn ich mir online eine hose bestelle
dann mache ich das ja aber ein händler
nur silber und m und co beim checkout
habe ich unterschiedliche
bezahlmöglichkeiten zudem bei neuro
pager optionen gehören rechnungs und
ratenkauf hier kommt dann der
finanzdienstleister wie paypal und co
ins spiel professor jürgen nur man weiß
wie diese dienste funktionieren
das sind dienste die direkt in einem
online shop integriert sind und die
möglichkeit bieten ja sehr schnell
möchte sagen in sekundenschnelle sich
einen ratenkredit zu besorgen und ja und
die rechnung dann über die zeit
abzuzahlen bei pay later ist formal kein
kredit sondern ist eine stundung
denn das ist ja eine reine
verkaufsförderungsmaßnahmen
durchgeführt wird und der betrag der die
händler zu steht der wert an zum
beispiel planer übergeben okay für meine
hose bedeutet das folgendes ich habe
einen vertrag mit dem händler und der
migros mit dem finanzdienstleister der
zahl muss ich meine hose aber über den
finanzdienstleister der gibt auch die
konditionen vor und schickt mir
abmahnungen und im schlimmsten fall das
inkassounternehmen nie deine pay later
branche boomt nach angaben des kölner
einzelhandel instituts war der kauf auf
rechnung 2020 das beliebteste
zahlungsmittel der deutschen mit einem
umsatzanteil von 30 4 prozent deutlich
seltener genutzt wird der ratenkauf er
hat lediglich einen umsatzanteil von
zwei prozent unternehmen wie planer aus
schweden paypal aus den usa 8 ap aus
australien und unser und ratepay aus
deutschland bieten bei no pay later an
für nutzer und nutzerinnen klingen die
option ja gut man bekommt erst die ware
bezahlt nur das was man behält und wann
es einen selbst am besten passt
vertrauen wurde das aber zum verhängnis
was ich da heute sehr kritischen nach
wie man sie ist einfach ist für mich
irgendwie mal die bonität abgefragt
wurde nicht wie mal darauf hingewiesen
habe auf kaufe ich so viel oder wir
haben erst eine sperre von 500 euro
eingerichtet brauchen kannst du kannst
einfach drauflos shoppen und es gibt so
gesehen erst mal kein limit up
verbraucherschützern an mir geht vorweg
sind eher eine gefahr wird ja immer
suggeriert das ist alles so einfach und
man braucht nicht mal mehr aufs konto zu
gucken oder auf die kreditkarte und
bestellen zu können man kann einfach in
jedem fall bestellen weil man bezahlt
eben dann wenn man das geld dann hat
dann ist es ja auch so auch man hat
vielleicht auch im nächsten oder
übernächsten monat das geld nicht wenn
man es jetzt schon nicht hat welche
erfahrungen habt ihr damit beinahe pay
later gemacht nutzte diese bezahlmethode
gerne oder habt ihr euch vielleicht
selbst schon mal verschuldet und sei
deswegen eher ängstlich schreibt uns mal
in die kommentare
einer der beliebtesten zahlungsanbieter
in deutschland klar tom waits und viele
tik tok user haben hier regelmäßig ihre
rechnungen aufgeschoben und sich
verschuldet ich möchte mit dem
zahlungsanbieter jetzt mal ein bisschen
genauer anschauen im moment ist es das
zweitwertvollste finanz tech unternehmen
der welt täglich werden weltweit zwei
millionen transaktionen mit planer
abgeschlossen über 250.000 händler
arbeiten mit kleiner zusammen klar dann
sind mit unterschiedlichen
bezahlmodellen dem sofort bezahlen und
den beinahe pay later optionen kauf auf
rechnung und ratenkauf die beliebtesten
zahlungsarten bei kleiner sofort
bezahlen und der kauf auf rechnung und
seit neuestem gibt es auch die planer
card mit der kann man sogar im geschäft
flexibler auf rechnung bezahlen das
klingt wirklich alles sehr einfach zu
handhaben und spricht natürlich auch
eine junge zielgruppe an gerade das kann
er bei einem teufelskreis seien erzählt
mir zumindest made da waren wir ein
bisschen wunderlich jetzt mal machen 70
und ich nicht informiert und die agbs
hat natürlich nicht gelesen
geklickt und dann branchen die wade da
noch einige tage darum so das glaubt ihr
sehr gut morgen nicht und das ist für
viele ein problem von zusätzlichen
kosten muss man bei der bestellung auf
den ersten blick nichts dazu muss man
sich tatsächlich erst mal durch die an
gemäss klicken und die sind lang ich
habe mir das mal vor ich durchgelesen in
der rechnungskauf hat keine zusätzliche
gebühr aber wer nicht rechtzeitig zahlt
zeit für jede mahnung ein euro 20
gebühren das nicht so offensichtlich ist
an wievielen mahnungen wird es kritisch
wenn die dritte mahnung nicht zahlt wird
als inkassounternehmen weitergeleitet
beim ratenkauf ist das schon komplexer
auf seite 1 der ags findet man eine
übersicht mit kosten dachten genau
bedeuten erklärt mir frau vorwerk wenn
man jetzt den anbieter kleiner zum
beispiel nimmt er nimmt für eine
ratenzahlung knapp 12 euro salz ins plus
noch mal eine monatliche zusatzgebühren
rechnet selber vor dass bei einem kauf
von 500 euro dann war locker 40 euro
mehr sind dass es sehr sehr viel also
selbst dieser bus kommen teilweise nicht
daran also mit einem ratenkredit würde
man dieselbe ware viel günstiger
finanziert bekommen der bank wird ja
auch geschaut ob man sich überhaupt
einen kredit leisten kann die nach das
kleine in sekundenschnelle es gibt die
identitätsprüfung authentifizierungs
prüfung und das ausfallrisiko wird
gecheckt und das macht ein solcher
dienstleister basieren auf den
zugänglichen datenbanken wir kennen aber
nicht die dort machen und auch nicht die
algorithmen mit denen errechnet wird ob
der kunde oder bis zu welchem betrag der
kunde kreditwürdig ist trotzdem
kritisieren experten und expertinnen
dass diese kosten transparent sind und
dass das markenimage und die werbung von
kleiner das beschönigen so sieht das
auch durch die werbung niemanden überall
sieht und geschaltet bekommt jetzt neu
mit lara bezahloptionen und man wird
halt immer mehr damit konfrontiert und
merkt so hey es machen so viele was kann
nichts böses sein so hatte ich es bald
wahrgenommen als er einen so schmackhaft
gemacht wurde die werbeaufsichtsbehörde
in großbritannien schickt schon alarm in
köthen haben werbung von kleiner
teilweise verboten dann nicht klar wurde
dass sich bei jetzt kaufen später zahlen
angeboten um eine art kredit handelt
verbraucherschützerin mit vorwerk sieht
ein ähnliches problem bei der
darstellung in der planer auch hier
seien die kosten nicht transparent genug
geben die verschiedenen möglichkeiten
stellen die in der app gleichwertig da
die möglichkeiten sind aber gar nicht so
gleichwertig klar sollte doch deutlich
machen welche angebote kostenlos sind
und für welche angebote man zahlen muss
und nicht die angebote von sofortzahlung
und ratenzahlung einfach untereinander
stellen und dann jeweils nur den betrag
nennen die man zahlt aber nicht die
kosten die darin enthalten sind das wäre
aus transparenz gesichtspunkten dringend
nötig auch um die verbraucher zu warnen
dass sie an diesen stellen einfach drauf
zahlen wir konfrontieren planer mit
diesen vorwürfen für ein interview hatte
das unternehmen keine zeit aber sie
haben uns per mail antwortet die kosten
die für unsere finanzierungsprodukte
anfallen sind bei jedem kauf klar
ersichtlich und für alle einsehbar
unsere kundinnen erhalten zudem
frühzeitig benachrichtigungen und
erinnerungen dass ihre zahlung fällig
ist so dass das risiko etwas zu
vergessen minimiert wird es ist wichtig
zu betonen dass wir kundinnen bei nicht
ausreichender bonität für unsere
zahlungsoptionen ablehnen nicht jeder
oder jede kann unsere produkte nutzen
[Musik]
damit haben sich ja trotzdem verschuldet
von experten und expertinnen finden dass
das bezahlmodell bei no pay later gar
nicht so leicht zu durchschauen ist
braucht es da mehr kontrolle in
deutschland dass dafür die
finanzaufsichtsbehörden basel
verantwortlich wie bafin warnt
onlinekredit käufen es muss ganz klar in
mehr transparenz gehen die
deutschen voraussetzen sind schon dass
ein raten plan im kunden zugeschickt
wird aber es ist die frage ob das
ausreicht wichtig es ja bei dem check
auch bei der schnellen entscheidungen
innerhalb von sekunden mehr was man
nicht an dass da der kunde reflektieren
was tue ich und zu welchen konditionen
tue ich das erfordert auch einen
transparenteren prüfung der
kreditwürdigkeit
er ist gerade für den ratenkauf nichtig
hinzu kommt die frage natürlich ob es
nicht doch eine art kreditprüfung geben
müsste so dass der kunde nicht
unversehens oder seine finanzen nicht so
im blick hat dann in einer schuldenfalle
und dieser weg aus den schulden ist
atmet hat das nur mit einer
schuldnerberaterin geschafft ich habe
mir die ganze tiefe
mitgenommen im gerät man einkommen ist
mein damaliges einkommen als
auszubildende und dann hat sie auch
gesagt
es wird ein langer weg würde ich also ja
egal wie lange das sein wird ob es aber
ich komme aus diesem teufelskreis heraus
ich möchte nicht mehr so leben heute ist
schuldenfrei doch tom hat es geschafft
trotzdem haben beide angst dass ihre
verschuldung irgendwann sei es bei der
wohnungssuche konsequenzen für sie haben
könnte ganz wichtig wenn ihr schulden
habt und die alleine nicht abbauen könnt
so durch hilfe ihr müsst ja nicht
alleine durch es gibt
schuldnerberatungen die euch gerade bei
hohen summen gut helfen können falls ihr
euch jetzt etwas fragt wie ihr kleinere
schulden abbauen könnte darüber habe ich
mit margarete hornisch gesprochen sie
bloggt über finanzthemen und hat ein
paar tipps für euch ja so ganz wichtiges
erstmals den status quo zu machen also
griechen kassensturz und ein mal gucken
was habe ich denn wie hoch sind meine
schulden welche schulden will ich als
erstes abbezahlen als wäre ich jetzt
irgendwie von der kleinsten summe aus
oder wie ich von der größten summe
ausgehen dass ich über die anzahl für
kleinere oder jetzt im gesamtbetrag
schneller für zeit nach veganen im
nächsten schritt sollte man aber auch
schon das habe ich denn eigentlich also
versteht man sich monatlich zur
verfügung und sie wissen ja alle was wir
nicht durch verdienen aber die meisten
wissen nicht wo es gebe ich das ganze
denn jetzt genau aus also sprich so ein
haushaltsbuch zu führen sich alles mal
zu notieren und aufzuschreiben und geht
mir jetzt mein geld auch hin weil dann
kann ich dann einfach sehen war habe ich
beispielsweise auch sparpotenzial und
das ist dann auch wichtig den rotstift
anzusetzen und zu sagen ich streiche ich
jetzt wie gesagt die sind schulden ab
und muss ich einfach zur priorität
machen ein kern schulden aber auch schon
vermeiden bevor man sich etwas neues
kauft und margareta hat dazu drei tipps
da muss ich einfach mir ein budget
vorher überlegen und dafür dann eben
sparen oder auch überlegen wie viel kann
ich jetzt für meine freizeit ausgibt da
gibt es eine faustformel dass man sagt
es 30 prozent von dem was man netto
verdient kann man für sich und seine
freizeitaktivitäten ausgeben die eine
variante zu schauen wie lange muss ich
ja jetzt wirklich in der stunde für
neues handy beispielsweise arbeiten sich
dann überlegen ist es mir das wird und
die andere variante ist aber auch mal
sich zu anzuschauen wenn ich etwas kaufe
wie wie viel und wie oft nutze ich das
wenn ich jetzt in teuren wintermantel
kaufen aber dann trage ich jetzt
vielleicht reiche jahr gelang dann ist
dieses kostbare wer ist ja niedrig wenn
es jetzt aber ein schickes abendkleid
ist das kosten paar hundert euro das
sich vielleicht zweimal im leben an ja
dann wird es vielleicht nicht die beste
kaufentscheidung
wer die beinahe-pleite funktion nutzt
sei es der raten oder der rechnungskauf
sollte definitiv das kleingedruckte
lesen und seine rechnungen im blick
behalten um nicht selbst in der
schuldenfalle zu tappen wir haben uns
hier auch schon mit anderen finanzthemen
beschäftigt zum beispiel meine kollegin
anna die hat was zum thema sparen
gemacht und zwar hat er sich angeschaut
wie die privat für ihr alter vorsorgen
kann wir haben euch das video hier mal
verlinkt
[Musik]